grand theft auto 5 s multiplayer mode
GTA online is free but Rockstar offers
optional micro transactions for players
who want to speed up their progress it
turns out those micro transactions are
proving wildly popular reportedly
generating half a billion dollars I'm
Dave welcome to your game spot news
update as part of form of Rockstar North
president Leslie Benzies 150 million
dollar lawsuit against egg too it's been
revealed the GTA online has generated at
least five hundred million dollars in
revenue from micro transactions to put a
number in context halo 5s
microtransactions bought in at least 1.5
million GTA online has the potential to
achieve the greatest profit margin of
any game created in the GTA franchise
this is in part because GTA Online's
microtransactions have nearly one
hundred percent profit margin except for
the development costs and fees clicks by
storefronts take 20 Strauss Zelnick set
in November 2015 that more than 8
million people were playing GTA online
every week he has also described GTA
online as the gift that keeps on giving
as it relates to the money it makes from
micro transactions as the game itself
GTA 5 has shipped 60 million copies
according to the latest numbers from
tech to the lawsuit estimates revenue
from the game alone to be in the area of
three billion dollars single-player dlc
for GTA 5 is still under consideration
but these incredible numbers for GTA
online may explain why Rockstar might
not be rushing to get it out the door
anytime soon rockstar has kept GTA
online fresh since launch constantly
adding new content including more modes
items weapons and cars amongst other
things just as recently as April twelfth
Rockstar introduced a new mode called
inch by inch and the vapid minivan so
are you still roaming around san andreas
with a pocket full of dollar bills let
us know in the comment section below or
you can find me on Twitter at a regular
Dave and for your gaming news stay tuned
to gamespot com
you